welcome to the Creator launch pad we
want to see your idea for a new original
show concept so get together with your
friends and shoot an episode we'll watch
your video and if we love it we'll hire
you to join our team and direct more
episodes click on the link in the
description below for more information
does everyone here wear jeans
yeah where do you guys buy your jeans
from that honestly depends I've had some
luck I mean I'm I present more masculine
so a lot of the times I will like
resource to Old Navy I'll just kind of
go there and like get one of the bigger
pairs I actually did just get a pair
from Old Navy like a couple weeks ago
and I love it but it's a little big in
the way so I do have to take it in I'm
probably going to tailor it though so
but I do love Old Navy's jeans
especially their men's section I don't
really wear jeans but I think the only
doopers that I own are from Xi'an I feel
like it depends what style I'm going for
like for fitted jeans I definitely think
like good Americans might go to
obviously they're like on the higher end
of like pricing wise but they like make
my ass look great well that's the thing
also like getting the confidence to
actually wear away you want it took me
forever so when I actually did I'm still
in the mentality when I was like 16 17
and I could fit in a medium so I'm like
oh this I can't go to the same stores
like I can't go to a mall and buy
clothes anymore I would say two years
ago I would go to like Goodwills and
value Villages but that has become a lot
harder as of late the reason that I
chose to do this was mainly because it
meant a lot to me to share the idea of
like as you transition away from being
in a bigger body to potentially being in
a skinnier body that is not something
that like makes you harder working or
better at like achieving some sort of
goal than the other person or another
person that you may see in a plus size
body and going into it I like promised
myself I wasn't going to tell any lies I
was going to be very truthful and speak
on every kind of experience that I had
had leading up to today I wanted to make
sure that what I was saying was stuff
that I lived through I think putting on
a character would be disrespectful to
the other people that were here today I
just Thrift most of my clothing and like
I have a tailor for my pants anyway like
back in Taylor yeah 100 especially when
I'm back home uh I'm 15 minutes outside
of New York City so I usually just
commute in there there's just one thrift
store I don't know if anybody's been
called the L train and like that is
really good for carrying bigger sizes
back in my actual Hometown I can go to
my tailor very easily it's like 500
drive from my house okay so I Thrift
probably 90 of my clothing cheaper saves
energy and like it feels way easier
there is no way he's gonna go pay like
15 for jeans then go pay 45 like I get
it as a plus size person tailoring for
some things great but I could not
believe for a second that he is
tailoring every set and I was like he he
is not fat anymore not gonna lie shop at
Ross a lot or Marshalls
and finding jeans is hard I it's a hit
or miss sometimes at Ross they'll have
bigger sizes sometimes they don't but if
it says stretch then I'm usually good on
it I actually didn't even share where I
got my jeans from when I realized that I
usually shop at like American Eagle
jeans in general are like a struggle
to find either they fit your thighs and
they don't fit your waist or they fit
your waist and they it's a struggle
oh man I did feel I guess invalidated in
the point because they were talking
about you know Brands and you know and
stuff that I can't really afford so I
thought my answer of oh I shop at Ross
because that's what I could afford I
thought that's what kind of eliminated
me so I was gonna say if any of you guys
did any form of like performance as a
kid I know we were talking about how
some of us were models before sorry
about names but how that affected you
growing up and how like the idea of
Performing and being on stage was
definitely more difficult for you than
your peers that is an awesome question
well you start since there yeah yeah so
I I was on the math team for my
elementary school which was like very
fun and I enjoyed it a lot but before I
first meet when we were doing practices
and such they gave us the best sizes and
I remember putting on the largest vest
size that they had and it clinging to my
skin and making me very uncomfortable
and I walk into the bathroom and I was
looking at myself in the mirror and I
was like I can't do this and I quit and
it really frustrated me that I let that
take away something that meant a lot to
me that was definitely like my first
experience with like it is
very difficult for me that outside
elements are going to take who I am and
make that a form of a problem as a woman
in a plus size theater Community it's
like I always got the funny roles or the
really unattractive roles and I'm like
I'm big that doesn't mean I'm hilarious
like bro we could talk about this
forever yeah so that that's super
powerful because performing and becoming
into yourself you either have to be
overly confident and fake it till you
make it or it will tear you down so I'm
very sorry that that happened to you how
do we all identify do we identify like
what do we use to label ourselves if he
has one A T thank you yeah I have a
weird feeling about that one for some
reason really I just I like just normal
yeah because I'll say fat and then
people be like oh my God fat and then
I'll be like it's not inherently a bad
word
that's the thing no but it is kind of
taboo because I was like oh yeah I'm fat
don't say that you're beautiful I am
gorgeous but I am fabulous
I do I feel beautiful but I am fat being
fat or plus size does not mean that
we're not active that we're not nice
people that we're not worthy like worthy
it really sucks when people treat you
differently because you're a size 18
rather than a size two or four when I
like for example oh great example I went
Halloween shopping and it's really hard
because like oh first and foremost
trying to find the plus size costumes
they're like oh it's just kind of
integrated everywhere and it's like
realistically you have 200 costumes here
but only like 10 are for plus size then
I go on to the other costumes and I was
like oh my choice is to be like a duck
or like
the plus size one the plus size
non-costume covered boobs knees
everything but the skinny costume for
the other nun was like tits out
and I'm like so I literally like my
choices like be a bubble bath or a duck
and I'm like I need a plus size section
when I walk into somewhere because we
have not progressed in human society
there was this brand that like that had
this big campaign saying they were
launching extended sizes and then it
came out and it was like completely
different than the straight sizes and
I'm like we are just asking for the same
thing why do they get cocktail dresses
and I get literally
shut the [__] up
what me
girl yo oh my God
out I am equally shocked I I just I'm
psychic I know I know one of you was on
to something if you think the mall is
still in the box and you wish to
continue playing the game please raise
your hand
I think the odd one out is probably
somebody who lived as a fat person but
lost the weight but usually a lot of the
times people that do grow up fat or you
know go through weight loss Journey they
end up being more fat phobic um that's
not in all cases it's not in all cases
but it like it does happen a lot turning
in on that like I really do think that
in my personal experience people that go
from being in a bigger body into like
becoming skinny feels some sort of
resentment especially because I think
they tie achievement to what they've
done for some reason like there's this
there's this very big principle of like
look at what I've done and they very
they push this like American Dream ass
mentality yeah like genuinely like I
worked hard and I did this it's like
well not everybody wants to yeah that's
fine but that's fine if you want to lose
weight do that but you don't need to
like project onto everyone else and I
would think if you were somebody who
lived that experience
honestly dating I've met many guys who
were like I used to be big so I
understand that being smaller is more
desirable and it's just like this
conversation just rubs me the wrong way
I've been met with so many people who
think like that and like the worst
person I dated was very fat phobic and
they used to be bigger and they lost
weight and they were like shaming me
about my body being like you know we'd
have better sex if you were smaller and
all that [__] oh my God it's the
connotation right like yeah yeah because
they like quote well I was gonna throw
up air quotes yeah because they like put
in the work that part being an air
quotes and like became uh into a
skinnier body all of a sudden they're
just like wait you aren't working as
well again not everybody wants to work
that hard exactly can we also go down
the line and maybe just say if we have
um been fat or plus size most of our
life um or actually that's great because
I wanted to say for me it was a little
bit different growing in South America
there isn't a lot of overweight people
obese people and I've always been curvy
so to speak and I was fine but I was
still like you know how they say you I
spend my skinny years thinking I was fat
so I moved to the US when when I was 16
and I started getting weight you know
the life here is different I wasn't as
active I wasn't doing sports anymore and
then I was on birth control so for me it
was hormonal imbalance that made me gain
a lot of weight but it really sucked and
you know in my own skin I'm gonna start
crying I'm sorry
um
you know like being skinny
and like now you're fat and like
everybody treats you different
I think it's it's difficult too because
you know I grew up I've been fat my
entire life and I've always envied in a
way like the I like I've always wondered
what it would be like to live in a thin
body and how people treat you
differently like I've always I've
dreamed about it and I think that is
really difficult when you like yeah
exactly you I understand what you're
saying like you've lived both and it's
hard because you know from people who
haven't it's just we don't even we can't
even understand yeah and speaking into
the whole spending your skinny years
feeling like you're fat I definitely
relate to that I'm a bulimia Survivor I
was bulimic for about eight years and I
also played volleyball and it wasn't
like in theater and stuff like that and
the only reason I stopped throwing up
and binging and purging is because I was
losing my voice and I love to sing
and I got nodes
oh no that's the worst oh my God I went
from
um mezzo soprano to mezzo Alto are we
all crying now
pretty much
um but yeah like if it didn't affect my
voice I don't know if I would have
stopped stop
it really broke my heart after you know
having to vote people out who in my in
my heart I knew were fat to just feel
invalidated and that just that sucks
that really sucks
foreign
because I wasn't crying I'm sorry y'all
so the eliminations is something that
we're wrestling with do you feel like it
took away from the experience it was
just like being in the space where we
were sharing our stories and everything
felt so heartfelt but it's just a game
but overall it was really awesome to be
in the space and have these
conversations that don't happen often if
you don't have fat friends to talk about
them with as someone who grew up very
self-conscious and didn't know where to
look and turn to see people like me I
take that on as an adult to speak about
these things and have these
conversations that we're still confused
about if you think the mole is still in
the box and you wish to continue playing
the game please raise your hand
I swear to God if anyone's lying oh my
God
if the lights turn green that means you
have voted the mole out and you win
if the lights turn red that means the
mole is still in the box and you lose
one two three oh no we lost one on the
count of three everyone can take off
their blindfolds one two
three
I [__] knew it I
wow I told a heartfelt story about
dating some of that film but you guys
voted me okay can we talk about a
million and one reasons why it was Derek
okay the only one that got me was like
the theater like I really could relate
with that so I obviously know that yeah
nothing there is not a single yeah so
when I was in fourth grade I was four
feet tall I was 144 pounds and my doctor
told me that I was morbidly obese and it
was a very like self-image wrecking
thing for me because it was he used
language that made it seem like I needed
to change as opposed to just assessing
what I was like I said everything that I
talked about before was true but when we
were talking about people being
incredibly fat phobic that go through a
transition of being in a bigger body and
then ending up
the quote unquote skinnier that
experience for me was I mistook the pain
that came with not having self-love as
being associated with a number on a
scale and as I kept moving the goal
posts further and further away from
myself and saying like this will be when
I'm happy with myself and this will be
the time in my life where I like the way
I look and once I do this I'll be happy
with myself
I was no happier than when I started I
just kept being further and further from
a goal that I was changing I am happy
not because of the way that my body
looks but because I can have
self-acceptance and that's a very
difficult Journey for anybody to go on
and me losing any form of weight played
no factor in that I hope that in
watching this video somebody can learn
that the horrible stereotype that they
have of plus-sized people whether that
be that they're lazy or sluggish or they
don't eat right or they're not healthy
there are people that are plus size that
are faster than you there are people
that are plus size that are in better
conditions than the average human being
I was definitely plus sized for a long
period of my life and I still feel the
residuals of like the way people treat
you for being in a plus-sized body like
to this day this is the first time that
I'm hearing a lot of these things
because at least for me growing up it
wasn't like being bullied or anything
like that it was just like my own mind
attacking myself like seeing in the
mirror and be like oh my God you're fat
you need to lose weight outside of that
like I didn't experience like the
bullying and name calling I didn't see
any of that so like hearing you guys
like that's that's a lot I couldn't tell
like how I had an eating disorder when I
was younger and how I overcame that and
then I slowly started drifting back to
it and I'm trying to lose weight now in
a more healthy manner so I wish I could
have told that story to the group I'm
sorry to anybody that shared something
personal and then like because of this
feels like they were lied to or like I
really I I came into the game with the
idea of just having fun and I promised
myself like I'm not gonna lie a single
time than when I speak it's like I
didn't want to like come in here and
build a character I hope people who
watch this video
whether no matter what size you are I
think it's important that we're just
kind to people and treat everyone with
respect I hope everybody just takes away
like empathy you never know what
someone's going through you never know
why someone's plus eyes I don't know who
made the rules but we can create our own
rules now and I hope that everyone in
the comments and everyone who's watching
takes that away and just tries to be
a better person more understanding
person